mythical zones are the most powerful
category of devil fruits in all of One
Piece and including Luffy's na fruit
there are only nine of these legendary
Powers such as the insane healing
abilities of the Phoenix fruit the
shape-shifting ninetail fox and even
this monstrous Guardian wol fruit and
considering how mind blowingly powerful
these fruits actually are we just have
to ask ourselves what would have
happened if Luffy had eaten one of of
these other mythical zones instead and
really what better way to start than the
first mythical Zone introduced ever in
the story and of course I'm talking
about the mythical Phoenix fruit eaten
by Marco and honestly ever since its
introduction this has been a fan
favorite fruit and maybe my favorite one
in the entire story but to truly
understand how Luffy would actually used
as fruit let's break down all of its
known Powers here now of course for one
being a Zone you get tremend tremendous
boosts to all your physical STS like
speed strength endurance and recovery
but you also get a full and a hybrid
animal transformation which in this case
lets you transform into the mythical
bird of Legends and of course just like
any other mythical Zone you also get
special magical abilities associated
with that creature for example with the
Phoenix fruit the user can generate
these blue flames of regeneration which
can heal you instantly as long as you
still have stamina left which honestly
if we're talking about Luffy here this
ability might just mean that he becomes
literally Unstoppable because as you
know two of Luffy's greatest strength
are his unbreakable will and his near
endless stamina so if he could instantly
heal from attacks with these magical
blue flames well there might be no way
to actually take Luffy out now that
doesn't mean that he automatically wins
fights though because Luffy would still
need to be powerful enough on his own to
take out the Heavy Hitters of the one
piece world but on top of these healing
Flames though this fruit's natural boost
to physical abilities would help Luffy
Advance even quicker than normal plus
the ability to fly and his sharp talents
would just add even more insane
versatility to Luffy's offensive
abilities like can you imagine Luffy
flying through dress Rosa slashing the
warlord doflamingo strings to prevent
him from trapping the entire Kingdom
plus the ability to rapidly heal himself
and his allies truly makes this fruit
one of the most perfect matches for
Luffy due to its straightforward
abilities and also sheer power Also
let's be real how awesome would this
scene become I mean just imagine Aces
red Flames mixing with Luffy's blue I
mean that would be simply incredible but
as much as I love this fruit even the
Phoenix fruit lacks the raw strength of
this next mythical Zone which is the
mythical human fruit model dutu the big
Buddha now it was originally eaten by
the former Fleet Admiral sangoku and wow
I mean can you just imagine Luffy
rolling up to a fight as this giant
Golden man with a goofy smile on his
face honestly weirdly enough Luffy might
have so much fun being this giant figure
that I could really imagine him staying
in this form literally all the time
though I'm not sure how the straw hat
ship would actually hold up with that
but size alone isn't the only benefit of
this fruit as well because we've also
seen the Giant Buddha launch massive
Shockwave attacks that can even take out
Cru of super strong Fighters and really
altogether this is another fruit that
honestly fits pretty insanely perfectly
well with Luffy's current fighting style
since he already turns giant with some
of his gear forms it's basically like
instantly unlocking gear third plus we
also have to consider that Luffy would
have probably been practicing with these
powers ever since he was a kid as well
so surely he would have had incredible
control over this ability like can you
just imagine the end of the fight
against the government secret agent here
Luchi but instead of Luffy launching
hundreds of Gear 2 punches he instead
crushes Luchi with a storm of giant
golden fists in other words he would
truly be a major threat to anyone that
he can get his fists on and on top of
that we don't really know if this giant
form is the full or the hybrid form of
sangoku I would kind of guess that it is
the full transformation which also means
that Luffy could still have a normalized
golden form with just extra power and
shock waves to launch at his opponents
and those same shock waves could
theoretically also help the crew simply
Escape danger kind of like the Cuda
burst on the thousand sun he does
anyways but as we'll see not all of
these mythical Zone fruits are going to
be as perfect a match for Luffy because
next we have the mythical nine-tailed
fox which was originally eaten by
Katarina Devon of the Blackbeard Pirates
now to be completely Fair we've only
really seen this fruit in action once
but being a mythical Zone fruit it has
the standard physical boosts and
Transformations at this time this
basically means that you can become a
large Fox which by itself is pretty cool
and I'm sure that Luffy would make the
best out of it but the true special
ability of this fruit doesn't really
suit Luffy All Too Well if you ask me
and that's because with the mythical
ninetail Fox you gain the ability to
shape shift into anything and anyone and
while we don't really know yet the
limits of this ability the power does
seem pretty straightforward and it is
absolutely perfect for spying or
sneaking into places by taking someone
else's form however this fruit does take
a ton of higher levels of intelligence
to really use effectively and if we're
being really honest that doesn't quite
fit Luffy at all if you know what I mean
for example can you just imagine Luffy
trying to pretend to be someone else to
get that stri he would have to act like
them talk like them and honestly I feel
like he would get found out in like a
matter of minutes or even seconds though
it would sure be funny to see Luffy
constantly messing around with the crew
and playing jokes on them kind of like
this guy here did during the alabaster
Arc but I do Wonder though how he could
actually use this fruit in battle like
could he shape shift into a bird to fly
into the air and then transform into an
elephant to smash his opponent on the
ground I mean I'm sure that Luffy would
come up with some sort of really
creative fighting application for this
fruit as well but it's really far from
the most impressive abilities to pair
with Luffy which as you'll see is the
exact opposite of the perfect mythical
Zone fruit for Luffy which we'll discuss
at the end but first we have a quite
unexpectedly awesome mythical zone for
Luffy to use as well because the most
recent mythical Zone that we were
actually introduced to is the mythical
Pegasus fruit eaten by this horse in
case you don't know is actually part of
Blackbeard's crew as well and if you
know anything about the mythical Pegasus
then you'll know that this fruit should
allow anyone to transform into a fullon
winged horse which honestly would just
be so hilarious to see Luffy Galloping
around with these massive Wings on his
back I'm sure he'd have lots of fun
giving people riots since he's ridden a
lot of creatures in the story before
himself but I really see Luffy using a
hybrid Pegasus form even more and I'm
really just assuming here but a hybrid
form should let him still have his
normal body just with the added benefit
of wings which would basically make him
just like this guy from Emperor kaido's
crew and man just imagine all the crazy
fun and Powerful attacks that Luffy
could come up with if he had a pair of
wings early on in the story I mean
Flying Kicks flying punches flying
headbutts flying butt slams I mean Luffy
would 100% make full use of this ability
let's be real however what you might not
know is that in some myths they also
give the Pegasus even more insane Powers
such as creating Springs of water with
its footsteps and also enormous
thunderclaps from its wings and so if
you started to include those added
abilities then Luffy would truly be an
incredible fighter just on his devil
fruit alone so yeah this fruit is a
surprisingly decent choice for luy I
think however this next fruit would be
the absolutely most hilarious mythical
zone of all and that's because with the
mythical snake fruit model yamat no
Orochi Luffy would straight up turn into
a full-on eight headed snake and while I
don't think that we've ever actually
seen the complete transformation of this
fruit we do know that the original user
Orochi could transform into these eight
giant hats which could move around
independently and all kind of had their
own personalities however to be fair
they honestly did kind of seemed pretty
weak when used by Orochi and while Luffy
would definitely be a lot stronger with
this fruit than him and probably use the
heads to trap and beat down opponents
I'm mostly interested in seeing eight
ridiculous Luffy heads with different
personalities I mean seriously these
things are supposed to each have their
own personality but I do bet that for
Luffy they would actually all be kind of
silly and I'm sure that the crew would
get tired of that real fast so let's
talk about this fruit's special ability
instead because the yamaton noochi fruit
would honestly be pretty great for Luffy
because it basically gives you eight
lives so if one head gets chopped off
you still have seven more to go which
now that I'm thinking about it we've
never seen Luffy in this sort of
situation where he's about to get his
head chopped off so now I'm kind of
wondering what if he got stabbed through
the heart would that still give him more
lives or not really I'm actually not
really sure but one thing that I do know
is that this next mythical Zone would be
the single worst one for Luffy out of
all those that we know and that's
because during wano we were actually
also introduced to the mythical human
fruit model Ono and this one seemed
super random actually because it was
used by this fox which I don't get me
wrong really liked but it kind of only
played a really small role in the story
but basically this fruit allows the user
to transform into a large monk kind of
mythical creature which I mean is great
for the fox because they get to become
human and gain the ability to speak but
for someone like Luffy who already is
human and the only benefit that You'
really get is becoming an extra large
human granted I'm sure that would add
some sort of power boost but out of all
the powers that we've discussed so far
this is definitely the least impressive
for luy I mean this monk transformation
isn't even giant size so it's kind of
debatable how much stronger Luffy would
even be than in his regular form but now
it is time for the single best mythical
Zone fruit for Luffy to eat not
including of course his original NAA
fruit and that's of course the mythical
dog fruit model okino makami and this
fruit you might remember was eaten by
kaido's child Yamato and man these
powers are absolutely in sane now the
normal Transformations turn you into a
mythical wolf or hybrid wolf human with
of course all the added benefits of
speed power Claws and fangs that come
along with being a giant wolf plus it is
actually a meat eating animal so that
gives you an extra boost in aggression
during battle and honestly if it were
just this alone I still think that this
fruit would be awesome for Luffy I mean
he's always gotten along really well
with animals in general so the fact that
he could become one and run around the
forest as a wolf just seems is pretty
perfect for Luffy but that's of course
just the tip of the iceberg because this
fruit's special ability is the power to
create vicious ice blasts and man this
is such a mind-bending power because it
is so incredibly useful in so many
different ways I mean just in wano we
saw Yamato shoot out ice blasts use the
ice as armor freeze things and make icy
Shields and that's just for combat think
of how Luffy could use these ice powers
in just everyday life You' basically
never have to worry about falling to the
ocean again if he could just freeze the
water to create a mini ice Island before
he falls in plus we always have to keep
in mind that with Luffy the more
straightforward the powers actually are
the better he is likely able to use them
and looking at this really objectively
the ability to turn into a wolf and use
ice powers are both pretty simple and
should be easy enough for him to master
in theory plus Yamato mostly fights
while relying on her own strength along
with her giant clubs so it's pretty easy
to imagine Luffy doing the same thing
with just the wolf D Powers as an added
bonus basically but now that we've
actually found the best mythical Zone
fit for Luffy the next question that we
have to ask is how much would the story
actually change if Luffy had this
mythical wolf fruit instead of his NAA
fruit and of course we're going to have
to still assume that Luffy still wants
to sail the world and become pirate king
plus he'd still get his fruit early on
in his childhood and have all those
years to practice honestly I'd like to
think that the East blue part at least
goes pretty much as normal he still
wipes the floor with all the Min of
villains on each island but one thing
that does change is that Luffy no longer
needs to be safe from drowning twice
because remember with his ice powers he
now has a way better chance of staying
out of the water if you can just freeze
the water before falling in however
Luffy also wouldn't be able to do this
so he'd still get much better at
actually dodging bullets and cannonballs
instead of just always bouncing them
back plus I've always kind of wondered
if his insane stamina and Recovery have
actually been tied to his NAA Powers so
maybe he wouldn't be quite as durable as
usual actually however of course as
strong as wolf Luffy would be he still
wouldn't be able to beat this guy
because he doesn't have hockey or any
other Elemental counter to the smokem
men's Powers yet and so unless he can
come up with some crazy technique to use
his ice powers to stop the smoke he
still needs to be saved by his old man
on this occasion however Luffy's next
major battle would go much much
differently because during the alabaster
Arc Luffy had no chance of beating the
warlord crocodile until he learned that
he had to get the sand logia fruit user
wet in order to actually punch him but
with mythical wolf Luffy's ice powers I
do think that he'd figured this out much
much earlier since anytime that he used
ice it would melt into water and that
basically means that he'd be able to
defeat crocodile much sooner and not
have to go through multiple rounds of
fighting plus I'm actually wondering if
he could just make giant blocks of ice
to help bring water to some of the
villages on Alabaster as well which
would of course also be a huge benefit
for the desert country in general and
since it's also at this point in the
story roughly that Nami gets her famous
climb attacked I bet that she would just
love to experiment with Luffy turning
the air cold with her ice powers as well
which could lead to some awesome weather
manipulation tack team attacks with nami
and Luffy which honestly might be needed
if Luffy is going to survive the clash
with the ice loia fruit user aiji after
the skypia arc and honestly as you can
imagine I'm really really curious how
this would actually go because both can
use ice so would Luffy be able to damage
aliji with his own ice powers really not
sure but I do know that aiji is still
way more powerful at this point having
haky and also the straw heads would
still barely escape this deadly
encounter I think and now assuming that
everything else goes according to normal
the next really really interesting
difference I think would come during the
climax of enna Lobby that's because when
Luffy takes on the government secret
agent Rob Luchi we truly get to see just
how powerful carnivorous zones like
Lucci's leopard fruit can really be and
since this fight would be a clash
between a leopard and a mythical wolf I
do wonder if this would bring out a more
aggressive and bloodthirsty side of
Luffy as well than we've ever seen in
the story before I mean as you know
we've never seen Luffy slash or cut
someone with a blade but he just have to
use his claws and fangs if he had this
fruit right so surely there would be
some sort of inner Primal wolf in stict
driving him to use his claws and I do
wonder if the carnivorous side of this
fruit might mean that Luffy is even more
willing to kill people than in the
actual story but without a doubt of
course the single biggest change in Wolf
Luffy story would come at Marine Force
because I can really just imagine wolf
Luffy's ice powers making a huge huge
difference when it comes to saving Ace
because remember Luffy had absolutely no
way of stopping Admiral akainu's magma
fists but now that he has actual ice
powers I could see him at least being
able to block this attack and with his
full wolf form he could probably put Ace
just on his back and get them both out
of danger really fast in other words
yeah we could very well see Ace survive
Marine Fort if Luffy had eaten the wolf
mythical Zone fruit however speaking of
ice I do kind of wonder what would
happen if Luffy tried to use this ice
underwater during the Fishman island arc
let's say because I mean we do know that
some master Fishman karate users like
jimbe can actually manipulate water to a
certain degree so could some of the
fishmen actually use Luffy's eyes
against him possibly it's debatable but
once Luffy does learn hockey then I can
easily see him having a way way easier
time fighting against the warlord
doflamingo during Dr Rosa because keep
in mind that doflamingo used his string
devil fruit to cut shoot and control
other people but with Luffy's hockey
coated claws now he could easily slash
right through doflamingo's strings and
honestly this would make the war main
power almost useless against Luffy
though on the other hand Luffy wouldn't
have any major powerups like he got with
his gear transformation so he would need
to already be powerful enough to take
down doy that way now of course I
suppose you could throw in Luffy's
Awakening at this point if he isn't
already strong enough and actually maybe
this would be the perfect time for it to
happen since doflamingo also uses his
Awakening during this Arc as well and if
Luffy did fully Embrace his wolf spirit
and awaken well it will of course come
with major boosts in strength strength
speed and recovery and the area of
effect of his powers however nonetheless
I do think that once wolf Luffy comes up
against some of the yonko it will once
again come down to his Mastery of hockey
that will actually determine who comes
out on top and speaking of the yonko you
might have noticed that we actually
skipped kaido's mythical fish fruit
which allows him to transform into this
massive blue dragon which comes with a
huge arsenal of Elemental abilities as
well and honestly it might just be the
most powerful mythical zone out there
but if you want to see why Luffy would
actually die if he ever ate this fruit
plus how he would do with all the other
Emperor's crazy devil fruits and you can
watch that video right here thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one